tras más de ocho años al mando la
ministra principal de Escocia Nicolás
ton anunció su dimisión durante una
improvisada conferencia de prensa en
edimburgo la también líder del partido
Nacional escocés gozó de una gran
popularidad social Pero su apoyo se
empezó a desvanecer durante las últimas
semanas por una serie de tropiezos que
la llevaron a tomar la decisión
sé que el momento es ahora que es el
adecuado para mí para mi partido y para
el país y por eso hoy anunció mi
intención de renunciar como primera
ministra y líder de mi partida
impulsaba la ley escocesa de reforma de
reconocimiento de género la cual
pretendía facilitar los trámites para
solicitar el cambio de género y reducir
la edad del procedimiento acción que
causó el descontento de Londres que
anunció su intención de bloquear el
proyecto de ley además el tribunal
supremo del Reino Unido rechazó la
intención del gobierno escocés de
realizar un segundo referén
Independencia el cual estaba propuesto
para el 19 de octubre de 2023 es torsión
convirtió la causa de la independencia
escocesa en una columna vertebral de su
gobierno desde 2012 Asia campaña
argumentando que era una forma de
combatir la pobreza y tener mayor
competitividad para 2021 en la política
de 52 años obtuvo un gran apoyo en su
reelección como primera ministra que
según expertos estuvo influenciada por
su buena gestión de la pandemia y la
oposición al brexit pero este 15 de
febrero wish aceptó su dimisión mi
agradecimiento va por Nicole storean por
su largo servicio Le deseo todo lo mejor
para sus próximos pasos continuaremos
trabajando en estrecha colaboración con
el gobierno de Escocia
permanecerá en el puesto hasta que su
partido designe un nuevo